und uns zu diesem thema ist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet oliver schröder journalist
und chefredakteur des recherche
netzwerks korrektiv herum 200.000 euro
in einem banksafe man muss betonen das
ist nicht illegal bargeld in einem safe
zu haben auch in dieser höhe aber was
denken sie was könnte das für geld seien
gut über das geld können wir uns
wirklich nur spekulieren also da ist
überhaupt nicht klappt tasten
zusammenhang zu dieser comics affäre
gibt aber es gab immer wieder
geldzahlungen da gab's zusammenhang also
gar nichts cars hat lobt für die
warburg-bank beim finanzministerium
bafin hat dem auch den weg bereitet so
olaf scholz und hat im gegenzug dann
steuer entschuldigung parteispenden
eingefordert und hat sie auch
postwendend bekommen insgesamt
45 5
entschuldigung 445 1500 euro wurden an
die hamburger spd überwiesen und
großteil des geldes ging an seinen
wahlkreis
es geht jetzt im prinzip um 47 millionen
euro das wäre eine finanz eine
steuerrückzahlung die die warburg bank
hätte leisten müssen und auf die die
finanzverwaltung in hamburg verzichtet
hat was vermuten sie warum warum hat man
verzichtet auf dieses geld zumindest
dieses geld einzufordern
ist er mittlerweile auch chat
nachrichten von einer finanzbeamtin
aufgetaucht die ursprünglich für
gefördert hat das geld zurückzuholen
dann gab es ein treffen in der
finanzbehörde also im hamburger
finanzministerium und da wurde um
entschieden dass man auf das geld
verzichtet und aus damaliger sicht war
klar dass es am ende des jahres verjährt
und sie hatten anschließend eine
freundin die auch bei der finanzbehörde
arbeitet geschrieben so mein plan ist
aufgegangen und da war die rückfrage
also wir lassen's verjähren die anfahrt
war ja es waren viele von vielen
finanzbeamten dieses geld verlieren zu
lassen und die ansprüche darauf gibt es
jetzt aber keine beweise zu beweis ist
nur dieser chat der einen finanzbeamten
das muss doch eine entscheidung sein die
auch viel höher gefällt worden ist es
gab ein treffen der waren hochrangige
finanzbeamte aus der finanzbehörde dabei
war die hierarchie die nummer drei
hinter
peter tschentscher peter tschentscher
war eingebunden also es gibt auch ein
paper trail hatte auch darauf
unterschrieben bitte mich auf dem
laufenden zu halten er hat auch cree
anschließend sie über das ergebnis
erkundigt und er hat nicht verhindert
dass man das geld nicht zurückfordert
könnten sie uns nochmal näheres diese
200.000 euro bargeld die er schon im
vergangenen jahr gefunden wurden in dem
banksafe gehören ja johannes kahrs
können sie nochmal genaueres sagen was
denn vielleicht seine rolle gewesen ist
also sie haben eben gesagt lobbyismus
als er hat verbindung hergestellt
er hat für die band ob ihr das ist
zweifelsfrei da gibt es auch genügend
belege
deswegen wird auch wegen ihn gegen ihn
ermittelt wegen wegen beihilfe zur
steuerhinterziehung deshalb wurde bei
ihm durchsucht und deshalb hat man
letztendlich auch dieses schließfach
gefunden mit den 200.000 euro aber die
wie gesagt kein bezug zu comics bislang
haben
johannes kahrs hat sich naturgemäß vor
den medien nicht zu dieser sache
geäußert aber viel interessanter ist der
fall ja auch weil es auch olaf scholz
betrifft was vermuten sie
er hat ja gedächtnislücken bei seinem
ersten auftritt
gehabt in bei seinem ersten auftritt vor
dem untersuchungsausschuss sie wird das
weitergehen wie viel schatten wird das
auf seine kanzlerschaft werfen
olaf scholz hat sich vor dieser ominösen
entscheidung dass man das geld nicht
zurückfordert mit dem bankier getroffen
anwalt dieses bank sagte auf einem
untersuchungsausschuss ziel des treffens
war es dass die steuer rückforderung
sich in rosa röckchen auflösen und es
dann auch schließlich passiert
olaf scholz streitet ab dass es einen
zusammenhang gibt zwischen dem treffen
und der entscheidung aber er kann sich
wiederum nichts erinnern als er muss
sich entscheiden entweder er hat keinen
einfluss genommen oder er kann sich
nicht erinnern und beides geht nicht wie
weit wird ihm das schaden als kanzler
was glauben sie
es wird immer weiteres tageslicht kommen
also diese affäre würde ihm das meine
prognose bis ende seiner kanzlerschaft
überschatten oliver schreiben war dass
investigativer journalist bei recherchen
netzwerk korrektiv herzlichen dank